those pictures colors this is then minute
peppers with gifts olive
this paper dat mark and tenth user
fireworks that you're used to
in two minutes papers profile that is
very important story that nice to be
told to add your
in computer science wie encounter many
interesting  problems by finding the
types of scrappy twin to give an streets
and a city or measuring the stability of
a bridge
up until a few years ago these were
almost exclusively soft white for the
channel and graphics
this means a glass of
technical design by and by  scientists and
there or a specific to the problem we
have trend that of problem that friend
every white
and fast-forward we few years ago your
appetite and amazing resurgence of neural
networks and learning and great as many
problems that were previously thought to
be to solvent
crumbles quickly one after another well
it is gland dat die ager vr is coming
and clearly there possible applications
of it dat me niet to be very conscious
gone since we design this traditional
technically with them the video cases of an
uncle lucas who is outdoor items of simple
enough that we can look other the world
and make reasonable assumptions this is
not the case with your own adwords
we know that in some cases more
alet were some be liable we this is my
markably hard to identify these many
your kisses for is so earlier Goedhart
debate so technique at the take pics to
kick drum i could make the crew drying
lawyer in french leading to reveal
image
adwords spectacularly in many  cases with
twitter was as if full of i samples with
whom liam using yellow dress is a beyond
the and reliability
who has a mars foger problem and that
problem is that were sharia body forest
in and become you're a piece of wood is
closet en fr  sa riera atom in which an
amusing i simple the added a tiny bit
of berlie perceptible most beautiful this image
to make the deep neural network miss
identifier boss for an astrid we
know from training and  new your
network this is pacific elite tailored to
break the wannabe half opening that the
possibility of target the turkish guests
to alleviate this problem it is always a
good idea to mee
sorry that is already adwords of kind
friend and adversary olympus is with
how  do i know how many possible on earth
ariel ik samples access dat we haven't
found yet
de paper discusses ow of verifying
import and properties ofnieuwe monitors
for instance i can measure the adverse
aerial robas mes of social network
en this is super useful piece  it cares
as information gathered a possible for
simple as that could break and learning
system
de peper also contains and max little
experiment with airborne collision
avoidance system de goal here is a
power supply afternoon collisions between
commercial aircraft where minima zing the
number of alerts
is a smartcard  experiment weekend
frame and your network to the place and
excisting system
but in this case station euro network
how it handles t  o be 5 out and it is after
finally a possibility
now make no mistake this does not mean
that there any sort of aircraft safety
systems diploid in the industry
darwin lying van je rollators no no no
absolutely love this small scale
when skye en of experiment that  may
prove to be a first step to something
wie lakeside think this is one of those
things for double peppers that one of the
we dat de you fireworks anyway most
michiel detail in my part of the
future this is a step towards the
future true weekend test  dat de
learning the great hem
is guaranteed to work in mission
critical systems he is also like to
note that even if this episode is not
meant to go viral the internet with tiel
en import hem story to be true
normally creating videos like this would
be a  financial suicide what wie
uw network by gerald biglia stable support
from you on page you and that's what it
is all about working class a views and
spending more time talking about what's
really  important absolutely amazing thai
sorry wat chinian folio generous support
en asia
nextime
[Music]
yes